welcome to this video black again this
is style or titi TA one ta one okay I I
think ty would probably have in not even
be allowed I don't know okay he's
playing the French exchange so no
relation whatsoever to tau okay let's
see yeah this is a slightly risky
variation for black but Queenie to isms
that puts black under some pressure all
other moves I think I'm okay yeah maybe
that one that that should be at least
them at least testing not completely
easy for black how do you play this kind
of thing actually 96 asking white about
the default porn how do you play with
that pawn their bishop a3 might be an
idea be sugar three hoops well yeah okay
well d phi of him but it looks it still
looks very loose this this idea really
wow
hmm okay I didn't expect any of that ok
bye going to I'm glad you just put
pieces out and let's see yeah there's
some way to actually make sure that she
does not I'm sorry that he does not
castle it's probably probably not
possible an idea form
994 you boo you will probably just
cancel and I take their notifies canijo
okay mm-hmm we should before you place
f3
Oh amazing
my fighting kind of strange this this
stuff should be should be working but
maybe it is okay so what am I going to
do here it's not so easy to play play
some to move even it's not very very
nice Jack didn't I didn't really see a
good solution
okay Jimmy maybe you can really just
take on d5 yeah I was just thinking
about it and hmm like them what what am
i doing if he just takes huh I don't
really have any any any square cm after
the capture maybe maybe a castle first
him c4 he can play with this is I mean I
think castle looks very normal no didn't
do that okay I go with C 5 moves like
this song you will take it
hey we'll take 16 but what else when can
I do yeah I all the wooden wonderful
opening result what a disaster Joe maybe
this G for business was strong him
looked really weird to me but maybe it
was okay possible I can take on 66 i'm
thinking of rook c8 92 check then yeah
I'm a pawn down and he got two bishops
so it's not good maybe I can still
continue to fight somehow okay he's
covering the e2 square that is certainly
making some sense
is a solid colored bishops but it
doesn't help me unless he allows Bishop
c4 which I doubt i think you will
probably take lady five-time morning and
it's unfortunately all very very easy to
play check trading rooks is not
particularly great for him but it's
probably not mattering much position is
too bad check
okay yeah show me show me how you do
this it's not it's not it's not
completely easy and trading rooks was
was very bad bad technical plane might
still be winning but so I wasn't
necessary at all I gets to have six okay
can still win it's actually no it's not
so easy because of the the wrong wrong
color bishop
maybe zoosk Vanya that maybe some soup
swung check all right it's got a zoosk
one at the bishop is particularly bad on
CA it could have done somewhere else
okay black resigns I'm at such an idiot
why don't I go here this is this even a
win right probably is this probably when
I can maybe go over here okay yeah Jen
then it's probably probably always lost
if it just doesn't trade rook since it's
just very very simple but here I don't
get my I don't get regrouped here right
jack says some way to regroup that
now let's say let's say I go here how
does he win this I am NOT i'm not
convinced
and the computer as useless gives + 2.5
and if that's ridiculous I think isn't
this just the draw I mean how does he
win this I don't see it maybe maybe you
can can do it with the with a sacrifice
like this look here and then here forum
for e6 a case somehow that sets it's a
draw but maybe you can prepare that this
this could be the winning idea so cover
this no yes okay that should that should
be a win somehow but even that is not so
clear can you do that I can go here
check I have no way to prevent f7 kingi
Aiden and later promotion or I have 17
g7 ok yeah so there's probably probably
win anyway it's still easier to keep the
rooks on ok I'd like to have to check
the Tsubaki opening what did i do what
what exactly did I do wrong and so G 495
mm-hm so maybe this this move wasn't
really cutting it this is what this is
what the engine is giving equal very
jolly funny line absolutely no human
player would take with this in a blitz
cape or maybe I mean without intention
may be but but not voluntarily we can't
put it here g to the comp doesn't see
anything I mean what I played is bad but
this was probably a bad decision then
compounds to do this it's probably
better I really only here realized how
bad this is tell they're just really
really really really bad hey Jack
yeah I mean instead g7 us directly
winning yeah okay and read opening bid
opening and quadrillion good a real
trauma there okay well thanks for
watching